[Music]
this marriage are you under the
impression you're the only one in the
building sorry did i disturb you you're
playing this other code but it makes it
quite difficult to concentrate apologies
Mozart helps me think I'm not sure those
assignments requires much thought I'm
not if we were to follow these inelegant
instructions there must be a better
approach don't you think I think
following the instructions is the way to
pass the class is that only one from an
education to pass your exams I wanted a
green don't you certainly but I'm a
student of science because well I I want
to discover new ways of understanding
the world around me don't you already
know how this will turn out
I find knowing how it will turn out for
your shooting discovered quietly Haran
Stein please
[Music]